mais on va plus loin avec une fois n'est
pas coutume pour seul invité anne nivat
karan vous n'êtes pas sur ce plateau
mais avec nous à distance au coeur de la
guerre qui se joue actuellement en
ukraine dans le nom basse ceux qui vous
suivent pourront d'ailleurs vous lire un
jeudi dans le magazine le point qui
publie votre reportage vous vous trouvez
en dans la zone encore contrôlée par les
forces du craignait nommé mais tout près
la ligne de front non loin de deux
nièces bastion séparatistes comment
vit-on cette guerre sur place
mais écoutez on la vit plutôt mal bien
sûr puisque la ville moyenne dans
laquelle je me trouve a été vidée à peu
près de la moitié de ses habitants mais
il faut dire qu'il ya encore ceux qui
restent et ceux qui restent c'est
important de le dire il reste pour
plusieurs raisons il reste d'abord parce
qu'ils ne peuvent pas partir tout le
monde n'est pas capable de partir tout
le monde n'a pas les moyens de partir
souvent les personnes qui restent ont
une personne de leur famille à charge
malades invalides mais il ya aussi et
ils sont nombreux dans le dans de basses
ce qui reste parce que il ne voit pas
finalement de raison de partir parce que
ils sont indifférents à qui prendra le
pouvoir dans cette région c'est à dire
que pour le dire crûment pour eux que
cette portion du donbass reste et
craignent haine ou qu'elle passe sous
contrôle russe ça n'aurait finalement
aucune importance ça c'est très
important de le souligner il y à aussi
ce genre de personnes en ukraine dans le
dos de base ça veut pas dire qu'ils sont
complètement pro-russe et anti ukrainien
ça veut dire que ils se désintéressent
de la politique et qu'il essaie tout
simplement de vivre en oubliant tout ce
qui se passe on est très loin des grands
enjeux géopolitiques que nous décrivons
quotidiennement ici sur cette antenne
oui mais comme d'habitude quand on fait
des reportages au plus proche du terrain
on trouve des ddd explications concrètes
qui sont autres ici par exemple la date
du 9 mai dont on entend beaucoup parler
dans les médias occidentaux
c'est à dire symboliquement la date de
victoire de l'armée soviétique sur le
nazisme dont on dit qu'elle serait là de
la fin de cette guerre n'est pas du tout
aussi importante pour pour les
ukrainiens pour toutes les personnes qui
vivent ici dans le bas ce parce que le 9
mai c'est très bientôt et personne ne
croit à une fin aussi rapide de cette
guerre aujourd'hui ici dans le dans de
basses et ailleurs en ukraine la
population pense avant tout à se nourrir
à se protéger et surtout à pâques pâque
orthodoxe
c'est dans quelques jours c'est dimanche
prochain et c'est une fête qui sera
également fêté en russie et tout le
monde espère qu'il y aura au moins à ce
moment là une trêve vous décrivez des
habitants davantage concernés par leur
sort au quotidien que par le pays en
tant qu'entité c'est ce qui explique que
pour beaucoup il se trouve toujours sur
place qui n'ont pas été évacués
oui comme je disais ils n'ont pas été
évacués parce qu'ils n'ont pas voulu
être évacués évacués c'est un choix que
chacun fait mais partir dans l'inconnu
c'est aussi pour certains ça peut être
difficile il faut avoir des des membres
de sa famille dans l'ouest de l'ukraine
ou plus loin encore en occident beaucoup
de personnes que j'ai rencontrées ici ne
ne considère pas une seconde cette
possibilité parce que pour eux partir
dans l'inconnu c'est encore plus
compliqué que rester ici et vivre au
quotidien une insécurité à laquelle
raphaël ils sont déjà habitués parce que
n'oublions pas qu'ici dans le donbass
nous avons trouve la guerre
d'artillerie les tirs d'artillerie de
mortiers entre les deux camps c'est à
dire entre l'armée ukrainienne et entre
les séparatistes pro-russes existe déjà
depuis 2014 c'est le coeur de la galerie
ci et c'est d'ailleurs la raison pour
laquelle souvenez-vous venir poutine a
commencé c'est-à-dire le 24 février son
argument massue c'était de dire nos
troupes russes rentrer dans le nuc
rennes parce que nous allons défendre
ceux qui sont dans le deuil basse et pas
à cause de ses échecs des échecs de
l'armée russe autour de kiev il se
regrouperaient l'armée russe est en
train de se regrouper dans le donbass
dans l'est de l'ukraine aujourd'hui mais
ça ne veut pas dire forcément
que
l'armée russe réussira à prendre se
donne base tout le monde en doute ici
côté craignent un bien sûr c'est
l'ukrainien du donbass pour qui la
guerre a fait partie du quotidien vous
venez de le rappeler depuis 2014 quels
sentiments
ressentiment éventuellement nourrit
style envers kiev et les occidentaux ils
se sentent abandonnés
ils se sentent si vous voulez les
occidentaux salle n'ont pas
véritablement ils ne ressentent pas
véritablement de soutien de la part des
occidentaux puisque le véritable soutien
pour les habitants ici serait un soutien
militaire c'est-à-dire une présence
armée occidentale ils ont bien compris
depuis longtemps que cette présence
occidentale n'arriverait pas en revanche
bien sûr en ce qui concerne l'armement
tout le monde est au courant que grâce à
cet armement russes notamment les
défenses anti char les missiles jaglin
sont très appréciés mais il ne serait
pas arrivé encore jusqu ici dans le
donbass alors qu'on vende il tourne en
rond de plus en plus besoin l'armée
ukrainienne ici qui a établi ses camp de
retranchement sait trancher ces lignes
depuis 2014 je vous le disais va devoir
quand même combattre en zone d'une zone
géographiquement qui est complètement
différente de ce qui se passait autour
de kiev c'est à dire ce sont des grandes
plaines c'est la steppe c'est un paysage
complètement à découvert et il faut des
armes de grande portée de longue portée
c'est pour cela on a beaucoup apprécié
ici que la slovaquie envoient des
missiles de défense antiaérienne
s-300 dont elle a énormément besoin mais
pour le reste tout le monde ici est dans
l'expectative et en même temps dans une
espèce de cynisme par rapport à un déjà
vu qui dure depuis trop longtemps et
justement une espèce de justement de des
désaffections 2 par rapport à la
capitale kiev les habitants ici sont
assez peur que le donbass ukrainien
puisse être dix ont sacrifié pour
pouvoir dire que cette guerre est finie
même si bien sûr à kiev ça n'est pas
expliquée de cette façon là c'est une
hantise ici dans le camp de base comment
s'organise la population et les pouvoirs
publics sur place pour compte guy but et
à cet effort de guerre
alors les pouvoirs sur place sont
absolument dépasser par les demandes de
l'armée justement ukrainienne par les
demandes de la défense territoriale de
ses réservistes qui appartiennent aussi
pratiquement à l'armée ukrainienne et
notamment ses deux mains sont des
demandes de logistique sont des demandes
d'essence d'essence de carburant la
région dans laquelle je me trouve il n'y
a pratiquement plus de carburant qui
arrive parce que justement elle n'est
pas ravitaillé puisque tout le monde a
peur de venir jusqu'ici elle n'est pas
ravitaillé non plus en produits
alimentaires en
médicaments qui manquent énormément mais
donc souvent j'ai eu en face de moi des
maires de ces petites bourgades qui
faisait tout ce qu'il pouvait comprendre
même de l'argent sur leur propre budget
le budget de leur commune pour pouvoir
téléphoner aux propriétaires privés des
stations essence et leur demander de
mettre 48 par 6 200 lits par là à à
certains militaires qui venaient leur
demander de l'aide notamment pour
utiliser des engins de terrassement des
bulldozer des excavatrices qui aident et
qui sont très demandés en ce moment à
renforcer justement les checkpoints les
points de contrôle sur les routes qui
mènent sur le sud vers la ville de dan
yates et vers le nord puisque c'est
d'eux par là de ces deux côtés que cette
région d'udine base pour être pris en
tenaille donc c'est ça aujourd'hui la
principale priorité des mairies et mary
civile ici dans le donbass on va pouvoir
demain un jour peut-être penser les
plaies avec cette russie que vous
connaissez bien
personnes que j'ai rencontrées
aujourd'hui dans le donbass même des
ukrainiens qui serait quasi indifférent
à la prise de ce territoire par des pro
russe dit qu'ils seront capable de
pardonner non le pardon n'est absolument
pas dans les têtes tout le monde est
totalement choqués par ce qui se passe
parce que ce qui se passe n'était pas
quelque chose qui était possible de de
pensée de concevoir donc ça ça n'est pas
possible mais ça n'est pas d'actualité
ce qui est d'actualité aujourd'hui pour
tout le monde ici c'est d'essayer
d'envisager l'avenir avec un petit peu
de certitudes or il n'y a aucune
certitude dans tout les crânes
aujourd'hui et encore moins dans le
débat l'absorption par la russie de
cette région du donbass contraindrait de
fête ses habitants à coexister avec les
russes dans un pays qui serait donc
demain la russie
attention c'est pas tout à fait aussi
clair que ça raphaël parce que n'oubliez
pas que les séparatistes de la
république autoproclamée de daniel sq
qui sont ceux qui sont tout près de moi
là ici sur la ligne de front ne
n'appartiennent pas ne sont pas englobé
dans la fédération de russie aujourd'hui
et justement c'est quelque chose que le
gouvernement de kiev ne cesse de dire
aux citoyens aux habitants du dong basse
ukrainien ils leur disent qu'ils seront
des citoyens de deuxième de troisième
zone ici on est dans ce qu'on a un trou
noir ce trou noir qui existe depuis 2014
qui s'appelle des républiques
autoproclamées et dont finalement même
moscou même vladimir poutine aujourd'hui
il ne sait pas vraiment ce qu'il va
faire qui compose les rangs des
combattants côté russe alors évidemment
il ya ces forces séparatistes pro russes
depuis 2014 dont beaucoup d'ailleurs
soupçonne des femmes et hommes verts qui
serait en réalité à le faux nez de
moscou d'être déjà présents
militairement sur place il ya l'armée
russe donc et on évoque aussi des
éléments venant de tchétchénie de syrie
oui il y en ad on n'a aucune certitude
bien sûr puisqu'il ya une bataille de
communication
de ce point de vue là mais il y a les
médias sociaux notamment les médias
sociaux en langue russe et russes qui
parfois divulgue certaine présence de
certaines personnes mais tout cela est à
vérifier il y à des combattants
tchétchènes qui son côté pro russe et on
sait qu'il y en a à marioupol qu'il y en
a
du côté des séparatistes du donbass mais
il y a aussi comme je l'aï déjà dit des
tchétchènes qui combattent de l'autre
côté du côté de l'armée ukrainienne la
chaîne fox si simple que ça la russian
fait face aujourd'hui à des accusations
de crimes de guerre joe biden évoque
même un génocide y at il de la part des
russes vous semble-t-il la volonté de
faire le maximum de morts civils et même
peut-être de vouloir éradiquer tout un
peuple
je ne peux pas répondre à cette question
raphaël mais tout ce que je peux vous
dire c'est que je ne vois aucune
différence dans et surtout depuis que je
suis sur le terrain ici en ukraine
occupé en ukraine en guerre il n'y a
aucune différence entre la façon de
mener la guerre russe en tchétchénie
tels que je l' ai vécu il ya 20 ans déjà
et la façon dont elle se déroule
aujourd'hui dans l'ukraine les seules
différences que l'ukraine est un pays
gigantesque
c'est un pays plus grand que la france
et dans lequel évidemment les exactions
commises par l'armée russe se voit
beaucoup plus grâce aux médias sociaux
grâce au grand nombre de journalistes
qui sont sur place et elle a la vitesse
à laquelle se propage les informations
ce qui n'était pas le cas en tchétchénie
mais cela importe peu à ceux qui
dirigent cette guerre en russie on le
sait bien et c'est ce que dénonce tous
les jours les médias ukrainiens l'armée
ukrainienne et bien sûr son leader
valdimir zelensky merci anne nivat
j'invite tous ceux qui nous regardent à
lire votre reportage qui sera publiée ce
jeudi dans les pages du point prenez
bien soin de vue on a hâte de vous
retrouver vous retrouvez évidemment ici
même à nos côtés en plateau et on se
retrouve nous dans trois minutes pour un
nouveau journal rester avec tous
[Musique]